the annual National Day flag raising
ceremony in Hong Kong this year was
watched by dignitaries and guests of the
government on TV for security the twelve
thousand attendees were inside the Hong
Kong Convention Centre for the
celebration of the 70th anniversary of
the founding of the People's Republic of
China officials were concerned that the
protesters would disrupt the ceremony a
heavy security ring was placed around
the convention center
Matthew chunk in Chung stood in as
Acting chief executive as Carrie Lam
along with a delegation from Hong Kong
traveled to Beijing for the ceremony
there he addressed the ongoing protests
now in their 17th week Hong Kong
citizens have been shocked and saddened
by the violence which has turned the
city that we all call home into an
unfamiliar place and we are desperate
for a way out of this dilemma a group of
about a hundred Beijing supporters
gathering here where the flag raising
ceremony was earlier in the day this is
one of several groups who have gone to
different locations around Hong Kong to
waive the Chinese flag and to sing the
anthem a small group of pro-democracy
protesters made their way close to the
venue for the National Day ceremony led
by an activist politician the group was
quickly met by riot police part of
intense security in the territory MTR
train stations across Hong Kong were
closed to stymie protesters from
gathering a protester group's petition
for a March was rejected by police
several rallies were still planned but
for those in Hong Kong who see this as a
day of national celebration not a
national calamity as the protesters call
it it was an opportunity to fly their
colors Scot hilar al Jazeera Hong Kong